taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to the mic i'm talking taste buds
all right taste buddies taste bud show
what up
sal how are we doing good how are you
i'm doing good
good how was your night my eye last
night
last since this is saturday it's a fine
saturday we're recording on yeah last
night was fine
beautiful day had some company had a
little dinner
laid back yeah yeah it's nice 70 degree
day today is nice
it is that guy we're inside i know but
like let's pick the
one day that it's gonna be the most
beautiful day of the year so far yeah
it really is gorgeous tomorrow i haven't
i'm off and it's going to be it's a 100
rain
i know i know i'm supposed to do some
with a friend tomorrow
and i text and i said it's going to be
pouring rain all day
it might have just really rained out the
plants
you know what i mean yeah cause what do
you think because you don't even want to
leave the house when it's like that
now i don't i don't want to leave the
house ever really
i'm having some weird thing where it's
like i'm having this weird like
i don't know like this pan that like
this they call it like i read an article
like it's called like languishing
it's like after it's like a ptsd after
effects of a year of quarantine
okay it's like i'm filled with dread
lately well i'll tell you this
i um i don't have dread but i do have a
certain anxiety
about going back into real life yeah
and i weirdly today found myself
very nostalgically longing for the
beginning of the shutdown
and like the way i felt when i was like
i guess i'm just going to sit inside and
eat cereal all day
you know remember when you were like we
were like figuring out what are we even
going to do
like i was watching up video games
and i was like here's the movies i'm
going to watch now like and then once
you got past the fact like i remember
like the first couple of weeks i was
like
i don't know what to do with myself
right this isn't right i got to get out
like a and then once you get past that
you're like
oh i'm settling into this right yeah
yeah
yeah it was uh yeah you might be
dreading the end of lockdown i guess
it's a feeling that everyone's having
yeah jeez wow
loving lockdown don't get i i'd rather
go back to life i just
i don't know what it is man i don't know
what it is it's
it's like remember in swingers when he
says uh
after a while you're gonna miss the
heartbreak
yeah and he goes when it when you get
over it and he goes why and he goes
speak the same reason you miss her
because it was there
or because he was you were with it for
so long yeah you're with us yeah it's
the same thing dude it's like you
you you look stucco they're talking
about stockholm syndrome where people
you know the captives fall in love with
the captors well that's
it i have it yeah yeah yeah
i have a stockholm syndrome to corona
yeah so
but anyway uh i also don't like this is
the part i most don't like about leaving
the house now
is i'm very cognizant again about my
lack of figure and my body
it was great when we just eat whatever
we wanted lack of figure is so funny
because it sounds like you're upset that
you're not voluptuous
i am voluptuous and that's my problem
it's the opposite for men yeah i think
voluptuous though
is past what you are i don't mean that
isn't anything oh
no i didn't know when i think of
voluptuous i think it's jessica rabbit
right i'm not saying you're not velop
voluptuous is a good thing on a female
yeah
that's what i'm saying it's opposite on
men it's bad if you're a man and it's
velocity but i don't think you're
voluptuous jessica rabbit's bursting out
of her
well yeah i don't literally think i'm a
voluptuous sound
comedy show sorry
you gotta stop turning every time you
say f and say bleep that
will he remember it doesn't matter we're
only just trying to get some more scott
alpha
notice some if an f slips by and upside
down
like everyone's like ah it's like
g-rated it's like no it's not
the uh by the way i just want to thank
everybody are you giving a speech right
now no no everybody writing in
i'm so thrilled with the comments i'm so
thrilled it's so fun
i love it i've been having the best time
ever with this podcast but i
particularly
want to thank the three people who still
find time every week to complain
about the free 4k youtube show
every week i know i
there's always there's about three
people every week
that have some some issue with the free
thing
uh it's like when you go up to a
homeless guy and offer him food
and he'll go like i did this once for
chinese food there's somebody
two times the homeless guy with chinese
food i went up to it i go hey buddy
i get all this uh chinese food do you
want it and he goes is there meat in it
i go well yeah and some of it he goes
strict vegetarian
you might want to loosen those
constraints a little bit but
i was i was on the upper west side one
time
um and i got out of my car and i was
late for a meeting
i forget exactly what it was might have
been i don't know if i was doing a
podcast or something
i don't remember anyway i get out of my
car and there's a guy i guess he's a
homeless guy i don't know but he's on
the corner he's yelling and he's and
he's
and he's saying he wants food right so
oh no actually he didn't say he wanted
food yet i had
food that i i didn't i don't think i
even opened it
i came from somewhere i was like i'm not
gonna eat this and i said excuse me sir
i have this
you know would you would you like it or
whatever and he asked me what it was it
was a salad or something
and uh he goes what's in it so i tell
him because he goes
nah i don't want that i was like all
right you know no problem and he's like
i would rather have like something else
like
like something from dunkin donuts and he
like points to the dunkin donuts
so i was like i was like all right well
i looked in my wallet i only had a 20. i
was like i want to give
20 i know he's gonna use it for i was
like what would you like from dunkin
donuts
so he's like oh i'll take like a
frittata or whatever he said right
and this and that and i was like all
right you know what i'm gonna go in and
get it for you okay
so i went back to my car i opened it i
put the food back in my trunk
i cross the street i go into the dunkin
donuts the dunkin donuts of course like
what other way would it be it's a [ __ ]
show in there no one knows what they're
doing
there's a line at the door and i'm like
oh my god i'm going to be late so i get
on a line behind like five people
and it's taking like 10 minutes to get a
frittata right right which is a lot
because
i'm late for my appointment what's a
frittata isn't that an
omelette it's like an egg sandwich or
something like that
so i wait i wait
[Laughter]
he's
[Laughter]
so i wait the whole time and i get to
the front and i ask for the frittata or
whatever
the frittata whatever it was that day
and she was we don't have anymore oh
and i had waited 10 minutes now i'm late
[ __ ] so then i i'm like what am i going
to do now so like
20. i just got like a coffee and donuts
and i go
back across the street and i'm like
excuse me they didn't have the frittata
but i got you the coffee no he's like i
don't want
he goes what kind of doughnuts i go
blueberry donut because i don't want to
i don't want that
and then i was like all right this is
this guy's problem at this point i was
like yeah i said all right no problem
like so i just didn't know what i don't
even know what i did
i might have just i don't know what i
did with it but then i walked away and i
went back to my car
oh i went back to my car and put that in
the car i locked the car again i had to
pass him again
and then he totally forgot who i was
like
from those two exchanges and when i
walked past him he started cursing me
out
cursing me out really and i was like
dude i'm the guy from one moment ago
what did he say why the weight online
for you with the thing and he just kept
cursing
i just was like and then i was like what
am i doing jesus christ yeah
i uh i had a guy come up to me the other
day and he said
do you have any food and i said no i
don't because i didn't and i didn't have
any money either
uh but then i went into a bagel shop
and i was like you know what i'm gonna
go in that bagel shop buy this guy
bagels got him
you can get you can guess cinnamon
raisin and then everything
in the bag brought it back to him he was
very thankful it was very nice
it was a very nice moment
i i was waiting for the other shoe to
drop no no it was like a nice moment oh
that's very sweet
i thought you were going somewhere i
would like because my guy was not nice
i thought you were like yeah yeah no i
was reflecting on how i said it i i felt
like it was like
i didn't mean to be like he was very
thankful so it was not i didn't mean it
like that i just meant like
it was like a nice human moment that we
had for sure every time you say like
every time now i'm thinking back and
anytime i did anything like this i
always end up in a conundrum
like one time i was walking we had the
season two premiere
uh like party for our crew for the when
the show came out in season two like
nine years ago
and we were walking from the viewing to
a a bar that we rented out after like
the production rented it out
and now a guy started walking alongside
me and he's like i want you know can you
get me something to eat or whatever i'm
like of course
and i was like you know like what can i
get you you know he said can i have i
think he said could i have money and i'm
like for what and he's like i want to
get something to eat and i was like i'll
buy you some meat
right and he goes okay and i go what do
you want and he goes like a cheeseburger
so i was like all right we were walking
it was like down by like um
the meat packing district like by uh
what's that famous steakhouse with the
cow on it um old homestead okay so we're
right by there and i go all right there
was like a restaurant i go all right so
i walk in there's the hostess i said
excuse me
can i please just pay right now for a
cheeseburger to go for him and he'll
take it when it's ready because yeah
rings that was 24. i was like damn i got
that's all that's steep old homes well
yeah that's a that's a heavy steak no it
wasn't the old homestead it was like
next to it oh okay
yeah oh i know the place you're talking
about yeah i know exactly what you're
talking about
yeah it's like wow and then i was like
all right that's what
i remember one time a guy came up to me
excuse me outside of a supermarket in
l.a
and he was like he with such sincerity
dude he was like please man
please i'm just so hungry can you please
help me please give me some food and i
was like
yeah dude i got you i go in
i'm like i'm going the extra mile for
this guy get him the italian hoagie
uh i get a full bag of chips the
family size bag i get them dessert cakes
right
a drink a water love it uh i think i
even got him like
some medicine and [ __ ] like like like
hey that took a turn
hey dude like here's like some like
here's like aspirin if you ever need it
or whatever you know what i mean
very sweet okay medicine i don't
consider that remember i got it
oh no i think i got him like uh i was
like that was presumptuous like like
washcloth things
i got him something i remember that was
like a toiletry that he could use
okay because he had alluded to needing
it as well oh okay
so anyway i just did the whole nine
brought it out to him
took it didn't even didn't even
acknowledge that i handed him something
it's a weird thing i wonder if it's
because like maybe they're not all
there that's or is it just that looking
in the face
of kindness and snub and just thumbing
their nose i usually dismiss it as
this person might have some issues going
on but when you look me in the eye with
the sincerity that this man did
and we connect like that i'm like he is
lucid he knows what's happening
yeah you know i was at the corner of
union square
uh like not even a month ago and it was
a guy it was uh they had a cart at the
end like a falafel cart
right there and it was clearly a
homeless guy right on the corner and
he's sitting like
in a vestibule and he was screaming
just screaming at people cursing and he
was just like i'm hungry
please i'm hungry and it was screaming
it was like echoing across the street
right so i was crossing the street i had
to go to an appointment and i just was
like
there was a flawful guy right there so i
was like i got you and i went up to the
guy and i said
uh can you just get him whatever he
wants i'll give you the money and then
you can make it for him and then
and he goes yeah no problem so i go
here's the money and i turn and i go
it's for him not me so pl i have to
leave so please make sure that
you get it to him you know like i don't
know if he's old you know right yeah and
the guy goes yeah yeah i got it i got it
so i was like all right hand the money i
turned to the guy and i was like
i ordered you whatever you want i gave
him the money you order whatever you
want he's going to give it to you okay
and the guy was like just he just
he just i guess he was just like well
just turn like the other way and i was
like
i don't understand what's going on here
right now
what can i do i don't know i don't know
it is it is weird when you feel
bad that you tried to help
a guy sometimes a homeless guy comes to
the rescue too because
i was yeah that's a great soundbite
the uh i went with uh it's rare
it's rare it's like seeing you know a
black albino but
i went i went with liz from the uh from
the comedy show the other day
to this deli i can't remember the day
time out before you continue
i'm now going through my mind because i
want to know what your definition of
comes to the rest of you
and i'm wondering on what scale there
this rescue is i'm going to tell you
okay
all right so i go with liz like did he
give you the extra nickel that you
needed
to stop you from getting attacked we go
to this deli in the it's an italian deli
in the west village
i'm blanking on the name of my apologies
but it's on bleecker street and they
make these gigantic sandwiches
and uh we each we get a sandwich we go
to the park and we're eating it and i
got this mortadella sandwich it was so
big that i ate half of it and the other
half i was like i can't even wrap my
head around eating the other half of
this
and then i and then i the guilt was
kicking in because i was like
i'm really not supposed to be eating
like this right now and now i'm going to
eat this again today
i'm going to eat the equivalent of
another full sandwich
again today because i have this other
half and when i left liz i was
walking with it and i was walking up to
the stand
because i had to check on some stuff and
a homeless dude came up and he goes
he goes hey man i'm trying to get a
sandwich and i go
well here you go and i just handed it to
him and i was like he just saved me
that guy just saved me i just helped him
and he just saved me
for me
what well that was a non-story no it
wasn't
it was a good story but i i didn't think
that that i wouldn't categorize that
that man came to the rescue
i'm saying he saved me for myself and
what i was gonna do with that sandwich
later
he saved you from yourself
in that case it was a full-on rescue and
he specifically goes
i was texting liz after and i go was
this guy clocking me from
deadly how did he know that i had a
sandwich on me i would love that he was
like
it was a mortadella it was a crazy
like it was so weird
for instance one time i didn't want my
sandwich
[Laughter]
no i did want it that was the pro that's
what the rescue is
i wanted it i had the heroine in the
needle i wanted it
somebody knocked it out of my hand a guy
saves you you know
one time i was at um uh what's a comic
strip
and i was coming out and i had like my
like a brownie sundae or some [ __ ]
in a bag and i wasn't gonna eat it it
was new like i took it to go whatever
the heck
and um a guy was outside and he's like
uh
he's like uh what do you got and i go uh
brownie actually i don't wanna you wanna
he goes
he goes i'll give you something in
exchange so
that's some magic beans what is he gonna
give you
no i didn't know either it turned out to
be performance
huh it turned out to be like a joke i've
had guys do that to me too
and i'm always like buddy save your
energy
what are you gonna give me and then he
it was like leaning against the thing he
picked up a
frame it was a picture like a what would
be in the painting
like maybe we could pop out a painting
but this like the gilded frame is still
there
and he picks up a painting that was
leaning on the wall he puts it up in
front of him and he's behind and he goes
nobody believes me i was framed
and i was like
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] that's really funny man i was
like that's that's what you're
exchanging for a brownie a la mode
that's really that's really funny man
that's really funny i'll tell you great
oh this
was you said brownie alamo a great food
prank i played on soda dan soder once
oh my gosh all right we're gonna get to
it i love it let me just tell this
we're gonna get to it we should 49
minutes and then just be like which one
you got
okay
soder had just quit drinking at the time
yeah
he had just quit all he had like 2013
was
food yeah all he had was food i'll never
forget this we were sitting upstairs at
the old stand the original stand
and he came from the cellar and uh he
came in with a bag and he had
he had to go downstairs do a set and i
go what's in the bag very funny comedian
yeah yeah let me assume you know him
bonfire
i go what's in the bag and he goes buddy
i got myself a chocolate fudge cake
whatever
it was from the comedy cellar he goes
i'm taking this home
i'm gonna get a little stone and i'm
gonna eat he was so excited
he goes downstairs leaves the bag i take
the cake i throw it in trash
i put a raw potato into the
into the container and close it and put
it back it was the same exact way
i did it like indiana jones like i i
cause i went in the kitchen and i go
it's got to be this way
yeah and i was testing different things
toss me the potato i'll give you and he
comes up dude
it was so hard not to laugh at him when
he was taking the bag he didn't suspect
a thing
and i get a text an hour later he goes
you mother
you have to give it up to you though
yeah you have to give it up to you
i have a thing with the guys on the show
like the guys you know
tend loins jokers whatever however you
know them um
since since we were younger if we're at
the dinner together or we're
eating lunch or we're together no matter
what it is if one guy walks away from
his meal
and does not say nobody touched this
that's it it's over
100 we either eat the meal give the meal
away throw the meal away
so it's all it's happened to us dozens
and dozens of times
each yeah so you can finally get trained
because you have right now you're
traumatized from it but it's like even
if we sit down at a pizza room we all
get slices we sit down someone goes to
the bathroom we eat his slices he comes
back he's gotta order two more
yeah yeah yeah that's just the way it
goes and you have nothing to say because
those are the rules
right the other thing is if you walk
away from your laptop because we're in
the offices together on set together
if you walk away from your laptop and
you don't either shut it
or if it's left open you don't say
nobody's allowed to touch this
it is open season on your laptop i mean
everything from
immediately jump into the contacts and
email as many people as you can
to try and ruin [ __ ] for you or change
every change the language to japanese
uh make the screensaver like just a
penis
right that's great you can think of
that's great i love [ __ ] like that i did
one time i wrote to um
este at the cell estee is the comedy
seller booker
yeah um really popular club in new york
if you're not from here
um and i opened james murray's i i got a
phone i
can you cut out dead air if i if it
takes me a minute to find this i gotta
find this i wrote to st from james
murray
you're gonna cry all right you got it
yeah so i found this so
so so james murray from practical jokers
you're writing to estee from his account
yeah she has no idea who he is no idea
okay september 2018. okay this is what
it was
i opened up james's email and it says
attention in all caps
comedy seller emergency hello este
my name is james s murray huge star of
the hit tv show impractical jokers
i am writing to obtain a spot on one of
your comedic showcases
please write back soon if you don't want
me to go somewhere else
i'm working on two hours of material
please be prepared to bump other comics
from the bill
don't worry about pay spank you
did you ever tell her no no
that's great she never replied and i
never told her
she never replied that is resolved dude
did not reply he knows i told him
immediately was he mad
i don't think he was made because i
don't think he understands like the
gravity
and the comedy world of what i did yeah
and that's the thing if you don't if
you're not a stand-up you don't know her
who cares right i guess she's the you
know she's
she books one of the the one of the
biggest clubs in the world yeah if you
did that to a comic it would be like it
would be like not cool
like that's not cool that you did that
yeah be prepared to bump every comic i'm
working on two hours two hours it's
great
spank you is my favorite part of it
that's great
oh that's [ __ ] great the um all right
so today our battle
is uh is well okay
you get heartburn a lot yeah why what do
you do to treat it
i i wouldn't say a lot but yeah i get it
i i'll take uh nexium or whatever it's
called oh
prescribed no oh nexium's over the
counter
i think that's what it's called right
nexium
the stuff you know like if you had it
right now you don't have nexium on you
i don't carry nexium i don't get it like
that no you can't take
nexium for more than like six days in a
row it gets it to go away
for how long usually for a long time for
me oh
you're getting constant constant
heartburn and acid reflux yeah go get
that checked out because you got to make
sure you don't have gerd
i know chris has gerd i think he is such
a mess
what is the matter with him gargaard
guard
is the word yeah no he i was talking to
keith robinson
and dante about chris today okay keith
and keith goes ah god damn it i love
chris but he's dumb
[Laughter]
he has a way of speaking in the most
simplest straightforward terms
that still cut through like a knife
because it's just so like it's not
this is a very simple premise great guy
dumb dumb and you're like oh man that
feels too real dante showed me did you
ever see the clipper
he's on jim and sam dante that's a hero
very funny comic
sent me this chris is on jim and sammy
zooming in
and he's talking about something with
jasmine and she comes in and starts
yelling at him from off camera and he
goes
guys i i got i gotta go i gotta go and
he
has to leave the job no
recently oh no
that's what he was in the middle of
saying when she told him to get out of
there
that's great he can just see him go i'm
sorry i'm sorry guys i have to go
okay here's how to get rid of heartburn
top top eight reasons wear loose
clothing
that does not get rid of heartburn i've
never heard that in my life stand up
straight
elevate your upper body probably mix
baking soda with water
i'm assuming consume it after that i'll
tell you what you do i'll just walk away
from the cup
nexium for a few days take licorice
supplements what's a licorice supplement
sipping apple cider vinegar chewing gum
to help dilute the acid okay
uh yeah what's a licorice supplement
licorice root
is it like when you get like the ginseng
root kind of thing
what's your take on licorice uh i love
red and i love black
in the form of a good and plenty only
that's the only time i like black
licorice still moving units they're
still out there dude
they're hanging on man really they're
hanging on dude there's a candy that was
a dominant candy in the 70s and 80s that
they just now people just use them as
stunt doubles for pills
yeah yeah right like when i film a
schedule like we need drugs ghetto box
is going to be yeah yeah
no they're going strong good and plenty
is the buick of k
of candies they still make pewdiepie you
know what i mean
yeah because my dad loved good and
plenties as a kid and it was confounded
me
i was like what are you chewing on this
stuff and then it's like it's just like
it's really an acquired taste i mean to
me the strawberry twizzler
is it's it's an un
arguable candy like it is it is a go-to
for me
what's that other one the twizzler's
competitor oh
red red vines red vines red those taste
a little different but they also are
softer in consistency
they're waxier um red vines are fun once
in a while
here's what the thing with red vines
every
craft service table you will ever see
ever in any shoot or any production
it's always red vines it's never
twizzlers i don't know what red vines
connection has or i made a deal with the
devil with hollywood or whatever
but red vines are good but they're
they're
they're they're it's it's there's no
point in doing twizzles versus red wines
right
they're the same thing they're not the
same thing and there's
i can't imagine anybody on earth is
going to vote red vines over twizzlers
no red vines have their loyalists
you buy both ends use it as a straw uh
sometimes
my big go-to at the movie theater is a
large cherry coke and a package of
twizzlers
and you use it sometimes i'll use the
twizzler as the cherry straw
yeah i'm a fun guy the uh but me and
patty walsh uh one time patrick walsh
funny guy follow him
he's also my podcast partner and we'll
see you in hell uh
follow him on socials not like on the
street yeah yeah yeah we went to a movie
theater
we went to the vista one day in uh in la
to watch something and uh
they didn't have sour patch kids so i
got sour jacks
and it was one of the hardest ever left
in my life we were sitting in the
theater waiting for the
trailers to start and we were looking up
reviews of sour jacks
and the reviews were they were they were
so
in-depth like what you found one where a
guy was like sour jacks offer a deeper
darker chew
[Laughter]
that was our favorite and then the
second favorite was somebody wrote
sour patch kids tastes like candy
whereas sour jacks tastes like
eating handfuls of shoveled horseshit
did you ever see the um the reviews on
like amazon of the haribo gummy bear
sugar-free gummy bears no okay before we
get in this will just be
today's a little bit of a long episode
god bless you all we'll give you a
little more content we haven't seen each
other in a little bit
so i don't have my glasses okay uh but
uh yeah oh thanks see you in hell
with this because you're gonna not want
to stop reading these oh
apparently if you a haribo gummy bears
that are sugar-free
apparently they are like poisonous and
turn your insides immediately and then
you shoot your insides out
and they people love and they didn't
know and then
everyone went online and was like this
just happened to me people lost control
of their bowels across the nation so
it's just causing it was causing like a
laxative effect
so now i'm telling you there might be 23
000 reviews i would say 22 000 are about
the laxative of effect all right
all right so go ahead go go for it oh
it's got a very low once pimp go over
and just
open up the one star click the four
percent let me tell you what happened
what because those one stars are
genuinely one stars
but the other so what happened okay this
is what what had happened was
people started losing their insides to
these things and putting them for one
star
it got such traction that they were that
bad
that people started being like i want to
try it i want it to happen to me
and so people were doing it and when
they then they [ __ ] they were like five
stars as
intended really yes so then it swung the
other way
and now it's twenty thousand five star
reviews because the laxatives work
okay it is all right hell has
one of the reviews was titled hell holds
no surprises for me which is a great
that's a great title
okay in my last it was my last class of
the semester
and the final exam was worth 30 of our
grade that's ridiculous
after a late night study session i felt
confident but i had to
i had to decide between sleeping in or
cooking breakfast my eyelids chose sleep
my stomach later regretted this decision
and after several uncomfortable stomach
growls i finally decided to make a quick
stop by the campus bookstore and grab a
snack before my test
since the semester was ending and
everyone was going home for the summer
a lot of items were on sale including
the snacks and candy that they kept up
front
being in the hungry state i was in i
felt the logical pick was the largest
yet least expensive candy in order to
get more bang for my buck
and there they sat two bags of haribo
by the way i thought it was hair bow
until just now
uh haribo sugar-free gummy bears buy one
get one free
what a deal i thought naively
i would eat one bag before my test and
one bag afterwards
why not one dooring uh as i walked to
class i gleefully chewed on these
abominable little bastards unaware of
the utter mayhem
that would soon unleash upon my poor
poor anus
i sat down at my desk as the professor
informed us that due to issues with
cheating on the in the past restroom
breaks would be prohibited
oh my god until the completion of the
exam i'll give you 10 minutes to use the
restroom now this will be your last
chance any takers
the demon bears hadn't released their
unholy necromancy
upon my stomach yet so my moment of
ignorant foolish i remain seated
still munching on those miniature
bear-shaped bombs
after the students wise and after the
students wise enough to take the
professor's offer and have return
the professor handed out the test i was
six questions in when it happened
[Laughter]
it started subtly at first almost like a
slight tingling sensation in my lower
abdomen
i thought nothing of it assuming my
intestines were just doing their thing
little did i know that my intestines
were trying desperately to warn me
of the horror that was on the horizon by
question nine it happened again
but this time it was followed by a sharp
pain and those infernal hellions
uh had orchestrated an attack upon my
colon i fought
to contain the groan and tried escaping
my lips oh sorry the grown that tried to
escape my lips
it was at this point i began to panic
something was going horribly
wrong i think that's supposed to be
right uh and i needed to get through
this test before it got worse this is a
very very insane like a lot of them are
in depth this is insane yeah this is uh
i can't read this whole thing yeah this
is this is
skip to the i burst into the restroom
yeah i burst into the restroom like the
kool-aid man and behold the handicap
stall was empty sun raised from the
adjacent window shown upon it
as if it was from god himself i took
it took less than 0.5 seconds to undo my
belt buckle pull down my pants and
finally relax my weary buttocks
upon the toilet seat it took absolutely
no expert to expel this demon
almost immediately the floodgates of
hell were open and the damned liquefied
souls
[Laughter]
i never felt such simultaneous relief
and anguish in my life
after 30 more minutes of this i
immediately went home dug a hole in my
backyard
and birthed her
oh my god 12 155 people found this
helpful
oh my god all right i'll do it
i'll do a person me or sal whoever has
the losing record
when we hit the year fully your first
full year of this podcast
has to eat a bag of these and we'll
shoot it we'll eat them
on camera and we'll do an episode we'll
shoot it yeah and if somebody's gotta
run
somebody's gotta shoot it i mean look
i'm no stranger at this i used to have a
bit about this
not the not these gummy bears but the
[ __ ] cramps yeah
i used to get them at least once a week
when you get on stage and you got like
a full hour ahead of you and it's like
happening at the beginning i've gotten
before my set where i've had to run to
the bathroom
and like i'm like desperately [ __ ]
in the bathroom and i hear the host
being like does anybody see joe
you're like and it's just it's the
anxiety dude it's like
one time joe you've heard of the fork
the fork you've heard of the knife
the knife you've heard of the spoon i
love this book
arguably my favorite spoon was magic
i thought the spoon already was magic
yeah okay
it's helping me get cereal into my mouth
that's right but i have a feeling you
have something more to say
well you know our listeners already know
where we're going because magic spoon's
been with us for a while and we're
moving boxes we're moving products here
okay that's why they keep coming back we
love them they love us
and the world spins round and round zero
grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein
which tell me another cereal where
you're getting that kind of protein
you're making gains
while you're eating cereal right only
four net carbs in each serving so that's
keto friendly how about gluten
nope gluten free how about green sorry
charlie grain free
how about soy don't you dare soy free a
lot of carbs no
low carbs what about gmo everybody wants
a gmo no you don't because it's gmo free
it's gmo free and i gotta tell you i
have no idea what gmo
is but it's not in there and i know
that's a good thing and you're not
paying for it
so look here's the greatest part they
got a new flavor i'm very excited about
this
birthday cake flavor i love birthday
cake flavor things
i love birthday funfetti
how about it's your birthday and you
have birthday cake cereal that morning
why are you waiting for the cake at
night that's right start the day that's
right you start celebrating when you
rise and shine and i'll tell you what
they got
magic spoon has birthday cake uh packs
available it's a special five pack it's
limited
it's available for a limited time only i
say this to you go get yourself a five
pack of birthday cake magic spoon
give a box of it away to your closest
friends and family on their birthday
what a nice present oh that is actually
a good idea yeah you can also build your
own box
make the flavors that you want to pick
the flavors you want they got cocoa they
got fruity they got frosty they got
peanuts and if you're in canada
it's available to you too as well right
now so go to magicspoon.com
taste buds to grab the new limited
edition birthday cake or a custom bundle
of your own
choosing today you're going to use promo
code tastebuds when you get there you're
going to get five dollars off
your first order that's magicspoon.com
tastebuds
and use the promo code tastebuds to get
five bucks off
this is your way to deliciously
healthy cereal foe
and i just want to piggyback on what you
said you're damn straight
you give someone a box of cereal for
their birthday they're going to be
thrilled
can we talk rituals
can we talk sacrifice what kind of
rituals not no not those kinds oh
good rituals get results okay you
wouldn't skip a leg day at the gym for
instance
and if you want better skin if you want
better hair if you want overall health
if you want all these good things that's
why
hawthorne is here they're making it easy
for you to build and maintain a personal
care
ritual sacrifice free okay that helps
you look smell and feel your best
hawthorne
it's a premium grooming brand that
tailors your personal care routine
to your unique profile these guys make
great stuff they really have nice
products i really like what they do
it kind of makes it fun too because you
take a quiz right yeah all right uh
ready
they do it in a quiz form right yeah
that's just you say that say the quiz
thing
it's kind of cool because you take a
quiz so they can tailor it yeah it was
great it was great i i enjoyed taking
the
quiz actually uh because sometimes when
i see that with a product i'm like man i
don't want to ask oh i love a quiz
i love a quiz i thought the quiz on this
was it was easy it was
quick and it was fun in a way because i
i knew that they were asking me
questions about my own personal tastes
and what i wanted
and i don't know i enjoyed it so at the
end in the end
i got an essentials bundle with all the
products tailored to my body type
in my lifestyle and one of the things
they do which i like since it's all an
uh ordering thing an online thing
is they take the risk out of shopping
because the first thing you're gonna be
like is oh what if it doesn't fit
all that stuff yeah they give you free
shipping on your orders and your returns
if you don't like the products
they'll even retail them for you based
on your own yeah
they're great they're great i was happy
with the stuff i received but i think
that's awesome that they offer that
service in case something
isn't a good fit for you uh these are
high quality self-care products that are
tailored specifically to your needs as
we said
looking your best has never been easier
and that's the other thing i like about
this company
looking your best can be daunting it can
be intimidating
it can be a lot of oh god i've got to go
to the fancy department store and i got
to talk to the person at the counter and
get the sprays and test the things
at the end of the day you go you know
what i'm wearing sweats i don't care i
can't deal with it you're talking
yeah these guys and gals and people
over at hawthorne are making it easy for
you to do your thing and do it right
without a hassle i love it
so take author's quiz today and get
started on your personalized self-care
routine
by going to dot c-o that's
h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e
dot c-o use that promo code taste buds
get 10 off the first purchase that's
h-a-w-t-h-o-r
n e dot c o promo code taste buds
get yourself ten percent off the first
purchase it's like one time we were on
stage and gato was like i got a [ __ ]
nothing i could do and he was just like
we were at a in an arena
and god was like i'll be right back i
got to go [ __ ] and he just left
he just left instead how long was he
going
he shits fast he was going like five
minutes but all right all right
like it was like but it was like it was
so funny it was like what i mean it's
like so
all right our or today's debate
wow that was the longest intro we ever
did yeah
we wanted to talk we're talking candy
today you know what it is from the title
snickers versus kitkat the poll has been
going strong
the pool's been up for half been up at
least a half hour
uh sal is team kitkat i am team snickers
yeah you know we talked this out yeah
and uh snickers was the one that landed
the spot in the battle first because we
feel like snickers is
a powerhouse and then we said what are
the few powerhouses that can possibly
face the snickers
right we came up with kitkat twix
i think that was it i think even though
it's still considered like modern day
i think the take five is probably the
best candy bar that's been introduced in
the last
15 20 whatever as a nuke as far as new
candy bars go
it's got a strong chance of earning its
place in history but they i think they
changed to take five
they changed something i think it's the
whole bar now
remember it was two pieces before i
think now it's a full bar
all right would it change something now
oh production costs
i don't know you know shrink flation to
combat higher production costs yeah
shrink inflation is what i was telling
you about tropicana yes
yes yeah yeah but here's the thing too
sal and i and this is important that we
note
sal and i as far as candy bars go
think there's nothing better than you
may call it that's correct
that is the king of all candidates
that's our both on our number ones and
it's not a lot of people's number one so
i was very surprised when you said it
was your number one
i was actually very upset when you told
me it was your number one
yeah because i thought oh well this is
going to be i'll i'll argue until i'm
blue in the face
this is going to be an easy one to do
south certainly won't have the same
favorite
and then you did yeah so uh but yeah i
mean the watch mccall to me
i once wrote an essay on what you might
call it yeah i told you that yeah you
did yeah
you used it for a program in the in the
uk for our tour in the uk they
they traditionally do programs and they
like a lot of color photos and they like
interviews in it
and so they sent us this list of
interview questions that we had to type
out for ourselves and then we're going
to put it in there and make this whole
like booklet
that's the thing and i was like i don't
want to answer questions about myself
i'll answer one
question because one of the questions
was like what's your favorite candy bar
right so instead of
doing like five page interview i did
like a ten thousand s
word essay on just the watching me call
it i put it in the
i put it in the program that we sold as
a souvenir for the entire uk tour
and i was like oh this i'll hear about
this is funny i didn't answer anything i
gave an essay on the whatchamacallit
right
to this day not one single human being
on this earth
has ever made mention of it to me ever
the good and plenty oh back to good and
pleasure for a second believe to be the
oldest candy brand in the usa the pink
and white capsule-shaped chewy licorice
was first produced in 1893
in philadelphia born and raised the uh
so here's why the whatchamacallit is
great before we move into the battle
today
it combines now obviously this is a
chocolate based
fight today we've already argued fruit
candies
we're arguing a chocolate based candy
now whatchamacallit as far as the
chocolate-based candies go to me
wraps up every it tastes like everything
you want from every one of the candies
together plus the texture is unmatched
textures on
the it's got the it's got the crispy
cookie thing from the kitkat
it's got the it's got the pink it's a
smiled peanuty flavor
you know from from any of your peanut
candies it's got the caramel business
going on it's got the choc it just it
just
hits it in such a perfect way and also
when it first came out it was when willy
wonka was still a candy brand
so it was willy wonka it was the
whatchamacallit it was one of the willy
wonka kings oh was it really yeah oh is
that oh that makes sense what's your
macaulay yeah yeah
so that was under the wonka brand yeah
nerds were under the wonka brand
that i know gobstoppers one of the show
whatchamacallit was under the wonka
brand yes
yeah wonka brand candies really
i thought it was like hershey's or
something that made it
actually i'm not sure i just said i was
i thought it was
i guess i'm wrong i don't know i mean it
sounds like it would be because the name
is very wonka-ish no that just says some
of the products
say pimp type in whatchamacallit wonka
you think he's gonna spell what should i
call it right i don't think he's gonna
spell wonka
oh really yeah wow and they got rid of
okay well anyway well i will say you
know just like anything else
all all candy all everything all food
across the board
is not as good as it when we were
younger no and it's less fun
wonka doesn't exist anymore now it's
just like i think it's just
nestling now or something it's like
something really just like yeah who
cares man yeah but here's can i on the
heels of that yeah
candy shop to our to our listening and
viewing audience
we decided that there are certain uh
food
products that we both agree on that we
think is number one case in point what
should i call it
uh another case in point uh the twinkie
we think is the best
right cream-filled counter-strike right
captain crunch with crunch beard captain
cartridge countries we think is the best
cereal
so we can argue it because we both want
to so we
we take it out of the equation we go the
next rung down right
uh but we decided that what we'll do is
when we agree on something
that will be something that we'll defend
and we'll bring on another friend comic
podcast whatever
to defend something against our yeah in
the future we'll do that yeah so that's
how we'll
we're gonna do those right that said are
you are you ready to lose
with the kitkat today well yes but
before i do that
i don't think i'm going to lose but
before i do that no let me say one other
thing that we
want to do in a few episodes from now we
want to do the first ever
fan voted yes battle that's coming up
within the month
yes so figure within a few so we want to
just have a within a month
for when this strategy won't have enough
submissions so can you do we have what
should we how we do should we do
via emails we do like how do they
message us what day
okay so there's on on the youtube no
press youtube page there's
a community tab and they could leave a
post there yeah they can comment on a
post that says what's your dream
okay so we're gonna put up a a a post
that says what is your dream battle
and you guys go on the no press network
page the community tab
and leave us what you want to see we're
going to pick one of those and that's
going to be enough people are already
doing it so yeah yeah
great we're going to pick one all right
you don't think you're going to lose
with the kitkat explain to me why
yeah explain to me on what planet you
think a kit kat
can go up against snickers really
satisfies
joe pesci never did a kitkat commercial
he did a snickers commercial
i'm not talking about how deep the
pockets are are they both do they both
are they both made from the same
i think kitkat is mars isn't it yes is
hershey and mars the same thing
let me just no i want to know if there's
nickers in hershey
snickers oh it is hershey kitkat was
crazy
no kick so confusing reese's candy
company a division of the hershey
company
and then it says nestle which was
acquired by nestle so what's snickers
then
i just want to know if they're they're
coming from the same family
bars is oh it is i don't know all right
okay so hershey and mars the kind of
thing going in
mars bar is a bar that's been around a
long time but really is
is always like he's it's a jobber i've
never seen in wrestling terms mars is
like
it's nobody's favorite but nobody hates
it i'll have it
i've never eaten one i don't even know
what it tastes like mars were big in the
80s they had a nice ad campaign here i
remember the mars part
yeah jamie farr do the commercials i
think you're dead
yeah yeah shamey farm yeah let's see how
many of our
our listeners get that reference so
what's in the mars bar it's chocolate
nougat and caramel so it's like a
chocolate
snicker throw an almond in that [ __ ]
no you're thinking of the almond juice
no mars bar has a nut in it it does
it doesn't it doesn't look like it buddy
what is the difference between a mars
bar and a milky way
oh my god there was once an american
mars bar but that's since been renamed
the snickers almond
yeah man mars had an almond in that [ __ ]
but there's a bar called a milky way to
the rest of the world
too wait what so yeah the milky way the
mars i think was the milky way overseas
but then they added so what's a marsh
here then
a mars here is a milky way with almonds
no it's
saying the mar that's not what a milky
way is
the bar is called a milky way in the
united states but everywhere else on the
planet it's known as mars
was an american mars bar okay so the
american mars bar was nougat it was a
snickers with peanuts in it
or almonds you know what's a real piece
of [ __ ] bar the three musketeers
i it gives me a stomachache i was about
to say like the milky way
nobody really cares for the milky way
they need to just refresh their brand
you're
you're
crazy older people if you're older the
milky way is a grand
slam candy bar you're out of your way is
like the mars bar
wearing as it never really made a dent
it's
no it's a staple it's a staple candy
it's been around forever
but guys sal joe
guess what what i'm going to the beach
babe oh well it's for work or play joe a
lot of us are going to be on the move
again this summer so my advice to you
take your rakons with you i know well
that's what i was about to tell you
about going to the beach and i'm
bringing my raycon
wireless earbuds why because i need
earbuds on the beach
i like to lay on my belly and kick my
feet up behind me
all right enough unicellular okay yeah
nobody gets that reference
i get it a little beach blanket bingo
yeah okay all right
and i like to pop in those raycons and
get a crisp
powerful beat in my eardrum at half the
price
of the other premium audio bring it baby
joe loves nothing if he doesn't love a
powerful beat
i'm saying that you know nobody wants to
deal with the tangle of the wires or the
earbuds and all that stuff
you want these bluetooth headphones and
the problem is you get raked over the
coals with these things
by half these other companies and raycon
is coming in
they're giving the you quality earphones
that are built for wherever you go with
quick
seamless bluetooth pairing it's super
easy syncs right up to your phone
uh the 24 hour battery life and
portability are great
you can take them wherever it's true 24
hour battery life is unheard of
i think it is it's crazy yeah so raycon
is offering you
15 off all of their products uh for the
listeners of this show and here's what
you got to do to get that you're going
to go to
buy raycon dot com slash taste buds
that's b
u y r a y c o n dot com
slash taste buds you're getting 15 off
the already great deal
you don't give you it off the entire
order this is not just on the headphones
it's such a good deal
maybe you grab a spare maybe you keep a
pair of headphones in the car i'm not
trying to tell you how to live your life
you got to prepare stop speaking about
you pairing a spare
that's 15 off at buyracon.com taste buds
by raycon.com tastebuds
hey buddies this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp and let me talk to you about
betterhelp
because is there something interfering
with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
for me it's
a man named christa stefano uh and
you know sometimes you have people or
things in your life that make you not
happy
and get in the way of just what you need
for yourself
and for me again it's been personified
in the form
of a man named christa stefano but
that's not a problem anymore because
better help
is here to help us it's here to help
assess the needs
and help us match ourselves up with our
own
licensed professional therapist that's
pretty great
i don't know if you've ever gone through
the health care system to try to do this
but it can be
extremely daunting and it can be
sometimes a process that has
no end uh seemingly but that's what
makes a service like this so amazing
they're gonna help you start
communicating in under
48 hours i'm telling you if you've tried
to just use the traditional routes for
this
that is unheard of this isn't a crisis
line it's not
self-help it's a professional counseling
service
and it's done securely online and the
service is available
for clients worldwide you can log into
your account anytime
and send a message to your counselor
and i'm telling you there's a broad
range of experts available here that you
might not be able to get access to
necessarily where you live under normal
circumstances
uh you're gonna get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
and you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room
as you do with traditional therapy guys
again i've been there
so many times and what this service is
doing
is so incredible in how they are
streamlining this process for you
and making getting the help you need to
get for yourself
easy and efficient which it should be
getting help for yourself shouldn't be a
daunting process
this is more affordable also than
traditional offline counseling
and financial aid is available
betterhelp wants you to start living
happier
today they want you to start that
happier life today
go to their website today and read some
of the testimonials that are posted
daily on there you'll see for yourself
how fantastic this service
really is go to betterhelp.com
tastebuds that's betterhelp.com
tastebuds and you're going to join over
1 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help
of an experienced professional in fact
so many people have been using better
help
that they're recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states
i can't say enough good stuff about what
these people are doing they're there for
you
it's a beautiful thing we got a special
offer
okay for the taste buds listeners you're
going to get 10 off your first
month this just keeps getting better
uh so go to betterhelp.com tastebuds
again that's
betterhelp.com buds
and get 10 off your first month do it
now
whenever anyone names that top five
candies milky way is not in it it just
doesn't do enough for anything i don't
agree with you and there was a time in
my life where i preferred the milky way
to the snickers because of the lack of
peanuts
the lack of peanuts yes that's snickers
biggest asset
oh look are you about to argue with
snickers and knock it behind me
let's stop digressing into the with the
other candy bars or wrong i just want to
say
terrible it's one step above like a
hundred grand in a payday
which they wouldn't be alive today if it
wasn't for bite-sized
halloween the fact that the fact that
the fabric who's walking into a store
and buying a full-size hundred grand
nobody what's a hundred grand exactly
what's in it
no didn't you just say that that's the
best new take five what's the 100
like crisp caramel nougat chocolate i
believe
it sounds good to me yeah but it's not
all right it's just not
done well and three musketeers sorry to
all the good people at 100 grand
but yeah it's kind of like whatever good
you
the only way i'm eating 100 grand is
when my niece comes home we go halloween
trick-or-treating the uh and that's the
thing dude it is a disgrace
to the to the business that three
musketeers has held on as long as it has
and is as popular as it is it is it is
like putting a marshmallow peep
inside chocolate it doesn't taste that
good stuff in it it's so
gross it's like it's nougat what do you
mean what is it it's a nuke it is
yeah it's it's it's just nougat it says
it's whipped
moose fluffy whipped mousse it's all
just
nougat moose i don't think that's nougat
it's all nougat can you just say
ingredients like what is nougat
what is nougat yeah it's nougat that's
what is nougat and what does it do
it's uh you know this is it's not a real
food
i mean it's you know it's but i'm
telling you is that considered nougat
inside of three musk
if you think what is inside that three
musketeers is whipped moose you're out
of your mind
we're on the official page it's calling
it whipped moose it's
what they could call whatever they want
there it is you're right you [ __ ] my
mouth they call it a sundae it doesn't
mean it is
there's no way that's whipped mousse
yeah it's chemicals it's made by mixing
a hot sugar syrup with a whipped egg
whites
until the solution sniffens cream
i don't buy that for a second um
here i'm here to tell the people that
work at three musketeers nougat cannot
carry a candy bar alone it can't it
can't
hershey's hershey's the hershey's
chocolate bar the straight-up person's
chocolate bar
is the only chocolate bar
to ever pull off the one ingredient take
on a chocolate
you can't even say eminem because it's a
candy shop yeah because and and they
and i know my point is this three
musketeers can't even do it with two
most kind of candy bars oh any candy bar
can't do it with two
yeah they need they usually need three
yeah at least right yeah
hershey pulled off a one but that is
because they have balls to the wall
chocolate dude it is undeniable
chocolate
that's it unless you got that around
your nougat which you don't three
musketeers
it's a it's no good i still don't think
hershey bar though hershey bar i think
is hovering around milky way territory
where it would never be the snickers for
me here's who i think would beat
snickers
kik could could at least give snickers a
battle you're not
cat twix reese's peanut butter cups
and i would say peanut m you might have
had a chance with reese's peanut butter
cups you might have
look the ad campaigns tell it all the ad
campaigns say it all
okay you're not seeing the kind
there is not the presence on your
television for the kitkat that there is
for the snickers
there there just isn't oh joe give me a
break snickers
no no no i'm serious no give me a break
oh oh
all right fine oh i'm sorry did the
campaign stick in your head
snickers did i not even have to you're
doing mention you're doing a campaign
from 86
first of all i remember the song from 86
it's in everybody's it's as relevant as
it ever was
you know what else is in my head to all
beef patties special sauce lettuce she's
86. yeah but snickers is really
satisfied snickers just had
eight like six major ad campaigns they
did stickers really satisfied
they did remember the one where the guy
would rant and he'd be like i was just i
was on my way
i should have had a stick i should have
had a snickers that was one of the
things
then they do the ones now with the
celebrities where they become other
people
and like whatever i mean they're
certainly dumping money into the
campaign
but there's a reason for it because
there's money coming in from the product
and when the product makes money then
you spend money on that product
well i don't necessarily agree with that
because that would indicate that kitkat
is this kitkat commercials these days
right so yeah when's the last time you
saw a kitkat commercial i don't really
watch it i couldn't tell you the last
time i saw it
pip i want you to go to youtube and type
in kitkat commercial 2021
and i want to see what comes up all
right sorry here we go kitkat commercial
2021
[Music]
commercial 2021. listen we're not here
what is this snickers nut brownie what
is that compare the
campaigns all right fine you're right
i'll tell you what though let me tell
you what the snickers does
okay you know what i i don't want to be
pleasant please go
okay i have opinions you got nougat
or whipped moosh as you like to call it
yeah for me
got caramel okay and you've got peanuts
oh and and we're talking uh and then
chocolate we're gonna talk to
traditional snickers versus traditional
kitkat that's what we're doing here
today right yeah i
was gonna maybe go into ice cream
snickers
you could tell me snickers is using
other things i just mean you're not
going to say almond snickers no no i'm
not going to say
because kitkat has no joke maybe like 50
flavors
no no no they have like they have like
they're disgusting the flavors are
disgusting
it's disgusting there's purple there's
like meat flavored ones and [ __ ] it's
gross
like it i think there was a buffalo
chicken one there was there was like
some crazy flavor
and the twix i think has crazy flavors
there too wow anyway then 15 million
snickers bars are made
daily uh let's go tradish because i'll
tell you something the white snickers is
an abomination to me yeah it's
disgusting i find it racist quite
frankly
but uh it's it's so gross so traditional
snickers
but i'm telling you something so this is
fun stuff right here go you've got
chocolate you've got caramel you've got
nougat and you've got peanuts
peanuts one of the only times i find
peanuts palatable
mm-hmm one of the only times i i
recognize that
like when they are drenched in caramel
yeah if you gave me a straight-up peanut
candy bar which they do exist what was
in goofy payday oh it's just people
it's it's it's it's with money
disgusting dude yeah that's nana candy
yeah yeah
that's right it's disgusting uh anyway
so
and and look with the kitkat let's be
honest
let's be honest once you get past the
the gimmick of that you can snap it into
pieces don't call it a gimmick
what are we talking about gimmick it's
not something that's been what are we
talking about it's for fifty four five
snap it off into pieces you have a
little fun with the first two when you
break them off
once you're over that what are we
talking about here
i i'm so sorry that you what are we
talking you're someone who gets over
that
you i don't i enjoy it till the last
chris i want you to talk to me about the
kitkat
as if you're holding the last crisp
there's no breakability
there's no more adventure there's no
more fun of pulling it out and looking
at the shape
snickers is um it's a powerhouse but
it's like it's there
it's it's reliable uh it's a go-to you
know
um it never blows my balls off
you know a kitkat blows your balls off a
kitkat sometimes
really really hits the spot satisfies in
a way that a snickers doesn't
i see i would say that snickers is the
only candy bar that i would say
almost could pass as a real meal like if
you were in a pinch
like when you got well the campaign has
worked on you well there were times when
my life
has worked on you there were times in my
life where i was really hungry and i was
like
you know college whatever when you're
really hungry my way to my 30
exam and i got a king size snickers
yeah and i was like that's holding me
it's one of my issues with snickers
what if you look at the regular size
snickers bar right now
it is almost down to slightly above a
fun size they have reduced the weight of
a snickers bar
uh they reduced it in 2009 a king size
is the size we used to get when we were
little
and it doesn't really set that's the
whole point it's like it's so small now
it doesn't really sound
fine well well they get a king size
they're not telling you which size
satisfies 400 calorie treats
yeah but they're not telling you which
size satisfies i have a lot to say
this is good stuff on the snickers i
want to focus right side snickers is
ugh i think that a snickers is like you
know what snickers is like it's like a
pair of khakis
you know it's it's it's it's utilitarian
it's serviceable
it stood the test of time it's there
when you need it it's reliable you could
dress it up you could dress it down
it's fine but nobody's being like
snickers
that's not true i think kitkat is
by way of the way that you consume it
immediately it starts off
on a better foot than a snickers because
it's fun
it's fun to eat the packaging is fun um
i like everyone i mean like probably
some people eat it whole
uh what what animal eats at home i don't
know but they can if they want uh listen
i break off one i eat them little by
little
you know what i do one two i break off
one i suck the chocolate off of one
until it's down to just like a
a wafer sheath then i snap into that a
little bit
i like that there's a crunch in the bite
snickers doesn't have a crunch well no
it's not a crush
the peanuts don't really depend on the
crunchy candy i like the kitkat has a
snap to it i love that
the the logo is embossed on each wafer
i like i mean it's like fun kitkat is a
fun logo you're not beating the snickers
logo the snickers logo is like the
raiders logo dude it's like it punches
you
like no no i feel like an ice cube could
have wore a snickers hat
i would have thought it looked gangster
you know what i'm saying yeah i see what
you mean by that but kitkat has the logo
on the chocolate
which actually had a great bit about
that where he's like there robin you
have chocolate
because they stamped the lettuce so i'll
tell you this about a kitkat and here's
a big problem with a kitkat
has a terrible melting issue i actually
find the melting
and when you break it apart that
chocolate starts to get into your
fingertips
and not in the way i like it because
i've defended orange fingers on here
with
cheetos or doritos or whatever else i
sometimes
even the ice creams the traditional ice
cream sandwich i've defended that
with a kitkat when that chocolate gets
in your fingers
it gets like it looks like when you when
you like roll up dirt
on your fingers you know what i mean it
gets so gross
and the texture of it and it is not
finger licking
kind of food it's like this is gross you
got to wash my hands but
yeah yeah but i'm saying but yeah but i
don't run into that problem
often because why i'm not a toddler
no but you're also but you are a guy
that likes to put a food in his pocket
for 20 30 minutes before he eats
a kitkat i said that to a chipwich
because it needs a thawing
okay so get a cat get a kitkat you want
to keep you want to open it right away
i mean i want i i you know what at the
movie i love a kitkat the movie
because i open it up the movies yeah
that's where i will get a king size it's
like it's like eight kitkats see i
open that [ __ ] and i it's good to share
and then i i open it and i lay it on
it's like it's almost like the kit kat
package
makes it a little placemat for itself
and then i have them and i
i like the fact that they're portioned
and then i could it's almost like i'm
having four candy bars
not one i really love
the simplicity of two flavors that have
not failed me
the chocolate in the kitkat is really
creamy
and it really counter balances well with
the crisp of the wafer the crisp of the
wafer is wonderful and the chocolate
flavor is very good
that's i i would not argue that at all
but
it doesn't stack up against the snickers
first of all let me say this
i would never get a candy bar at a movie
theater ever snickers or not i wouldn't
do it it's just not it's
it's not a long enough food i like a
long
food at the movie theater like if like
in other words if i get a
bucket of popcorn if i get a hot dog
yeah i get
i get to shower patch kids for for the
movie part the hot dog is like the app
like i eat it before the trailers even
start
and i get the sound or i get the
twizzlers like i said earlier or the
raisinettes
peanut m ms sometimes you know what i
mean i would never go candy bar at a
movie theater
that said snow caps uh snowcaps are the
worst
arguably the worst candy that's ever
existed are you kidding me right now
nonpareils is that they're cold snow
caps
snow you don't like snow caps snow caps
are the number one movie candy
there's what we'll have to go all right
all right all right
snow caps let's do movie candies
you want to just name two though you
want to be raising that against the snow
cap i'll do twizzlers versus snow caps
movies
every every movie theater has a big bag
of twizzlers i get the jumbo
i'll take snow caps against twizzlers
all right we're digressing
all day all right all right mark it down
pimp mark it down that's an episode
best better movie theater candy yeah
that's how that's got to be framing
yeah okay let's get back to yeah let's
get back to
the the subject of sure uh you won't buy
it
at the theater no yeah go ahead
snickers like again i'm saying though
once you hate on a snickers but i'm
gonna tell you
once you take away you you keep kind of
resorting
resorting back to my initial point once
you take away the
the uh let's call it the privilege uh
that kit kat gives you
in the way that you in which you can eat
it there's not a big leg to stand on
anymore
remember when they made and nobody
wanted it nobody ate it remember when
they made the full-sized
kit-kat candy bar nobody wanted nobody
they still make it i love it i think it
outdoes the original you're nuts
nobody loved it nobody ate it you get
this thing it's so
freaking good man it's like everything
you like about a kitkat but amplified
it's like taking one of the sticks and
just giving it like
human growth hormone who's ever eaten
i've never literally
never seen a human being buy one of
these it's chunkier and thus creamier
and the wafers are bigger and thus they
yield a lot a larger snap
so it's everything you love about the
kitkat amplified joe what is it with you
with food that snaps
you say that a lot well i don't know if
i've ever said that i think you say that
a lot
you like you you like something that
snaps something you can break apart
jiggle around in your hand a tactile
experience yeah all right so
that's i mean that's a big thing a big
component of foods is how they play off
each other texture
how many times have you gotten that
full-sized candy bar kit kit
numerous give me a number
joe
in my life 30. i don't know 30. okay
yeah
all right i got a very high number well
i mean i don't have that i don't
i i had less i mean i kicked cat once or
twice i don't really eat candy bars but
like
you know like back in the day when i was
really like hanging like when i was
really messing with the candy bars right
i would get that was like a go-to all
right here's the thing about like
snickers
it snickers underwhelming a horse by the
way
can we read these fun facts because
they're like really they were making me
laugh yeah
snickers bars were named after a horse
the chocolate-coated peanut caramel and
nougat bar
was named after the mars family's
favorite horse oh my god they named it
after their horse
each bar is a peanut limit you might not
be counting how many peanuts are in the
chocolate bar
when you're devouring it but the number
of nuts per bar is always the same
each regular size bar contains 16
peanuts
had no idea look at this there's a
snickers salad that's
never saw that with kitkats there's a
snickers blizzard they don't have a
kitkat blizzard they're not going there
they
they have snickers they have snickers uh
like
like like if you go into like a
friendlies or something they have like a
snickers sundae or whatever they don't
do that with kitkats they just don't
read that snickers are the best-selling
candy bars in the world
with global sales of 3.6 billion
3.6 billion 3.6
billion dollars snickers are the number
one best-selling candy bar in the world
next to cadbury dairy milk milka
dove and reese's not you're not even on
the
table bro you're not even on the table
look dude that goofy european candy bar
outsells your kitkat every time i bite
into a snickers too it's like
that like this pulling of the caramel as
you pull it away from your mouth
it always falls over and like then falls
into my mouth like lips and beer and
every time you talk about the chocolate
on your fingers when i bite a kitkat
it's always like
oh i gotta go like this to my lip
because the caramel
falls on it and then i got a whole like
you want to talk about great packaging
let's talk about great packaging what
you do with the stickers you don't take
the wrapper off
you peel it down like a banana and you
eat the packaging
and it protects the wrappers talking
about that it protects your fingers
brown is gross it protects your hand
you peel it down like a banana and you
eat the bar you could you could do the
same thing with a kitkat
i think that they couldn't not if you
want to have your little fun tactile
experience with it you can't
think the kitkat packaging is more
iconic it's it's it's orange so it's
more of a stamp of a brand you think
you almost think orange sound you think
of kitkat that's the orange
that's the current kitkat packaging look
at that right there it's not orange it's
red first of all
but second of all that's the new kitkat
packaging it's terrible
it's so boring it looks like but joe
here's my thing
doesn't need to do anything clearly they
do because they don't got 3.6 billion in
sales you tell me when kitkat came out
i mean they've done it it's 85 years old
1935. yeah
whoa yeah so kitkat's been around like
what is that
70 80 2080 puts into 2000
86 years all right okay 86 years
because it's been around longer 86 years
but i'm saying five years long but 86
years
on chocolate and a wafer the combination
has to be perfect for this thing to sell
itself out
for 86 years two simple ingredients i
have a counter argument for that pimp
how long has three musketeers been
around
show me how long three musketeers has
been around if we're gonna just base it
on longevity
you notice that i'm trying not to get
heated in this episode i know i'm trying
too can i tell you three musketeers 1932
even older than the 30s the 30s big year
yeah yeah even older than the kitkat
depressing and it is
dog [ __ ] and it's still around so you
can't make the argument of longevity
you can't i'm not saying the kitkat
doesn't taste good
i'm saying pound for pound it can't
stand up
to the perfection of a snickers bar it's
a perfect candy bar
it is the candy bar i would put about
five candy bars
in this class and i would put kitkat
snickers
peanut m m's reese's peels
don't count that's not a candy bar why
it's not a candy bar
it's in the same class no it's not a kit
bar
has to be part of it it's packaged
chocolate treats
no then you're then you could say
boardwalk fudge counts as a candy bar
oh you don't think eminem's chocolate
chips are a candy bar then
i mean no no truly don't believe that
emma no
m's no so eminem's couldn't even battle
any of these bars
you could battle it but it's not a candy
bar eminem's could battle
anything i think it's an honorary candy
no it's not
it's not a bar it's gotta be a bar
pieces
it's not that that's exactly reese's
pieces it's not a candy bar
but my thing is a wafer it's like saying
a reese's peanut butter cup it's a candy
bar it's you know yeah
i batch it crazy if you don't think it's
in the same class it's a candy
it's packaged chocolate in a bag that's
i swear to god i really didn't think i
was going to raise my voices
this episode i really didn't i got here
the last three episodes and i think it
was affecting my mental state and now
so i was just going to be calm a lot of
times i put my hand on and i pinch my
legs so i don't get mad at you
no you don't yes i do when i see a
little thing in my head like just calm
down just breathing exercises
because you're not seeing it because i
looked and i turned up i turned a shade
of purple one time
and i'm like i can't do this because i'm
going to have a mini stream listen to me
and i also i don't want to yell at you
you're my friend so
sometimes i'm like can we have a
civilized debate nothing's not getting
first i want you to know that
first of all black and blue on the side
of my left thigh because i'm trying to
bite my
let me say this to the entire audience
that i want to be on record saying it
nothing would make me happier
than if he died of a stroke on this show
arguing peanut m m's it would be
the best thing that ever happened to me
in my life
first of all don't you got to speak true
truth only
dude it'd be over i'd jump right into
hey babe
and and we're and that's a that's a wrap
and chrissy d run with it
listen to me you know what i don't know
no but i'm stuck on this right now i
think
i can't kids at large i think uh would
like kit kats better
than snickers because again i'm stuck on
experience it is to eat i'm stuck on the
m
m's thing you they're not there's a lot
of
chocolate candy it's a chocolate candy
it's a candy
bar to go against a an m mr peanut m m
if not
go against it i don't know like i i feel
it's
synonymous with snickers you could pit
it against the snickers i'm just saying
it's not a candy bar you could pit it
against skittles where do you put it
introducing eminem's brand new candy
bars in original milk chocolate so they
have a version of the candy bar now yeah
and they're they're going out of their
way to tell you we have candy bars now
because our other thing is in a candy
bar they're candy pieces
that's fine that's not what a candy bar
is joe i'm not arguing the semantics of
the
if it's a bomb no but no no
you're being literal no no i'm not
that's no you're saying
sal you're not saying it's it's a candy
it's a chocolate my point is too you
could say you could say
so skittles count as a candy bar because
they're because they're in the candy
store
not chocolate based a chocolate based
soy kids a candy bar has to be chocolate
based
pretty much no name a non-chocolate
candy bar i know there's one
day you consider payday candy bar yes i
mean it's an outlier bro
it's a candy bar know why it's a candy
bar
because it's candy but it's a
bar but it's not dumb but it's not
you're
that's that's crazy talk i'm trying to
stay calm that's crazy candy bar
is a type of candy in the shape of a bar
why do you do this the most common type
of candy bar is a chocolate bar
there's no candy in a payday i don't
care
it's the picture next to the definition
of candy bar
no it's as canned
no i think it's got candy in there oh my
god it's got nougat in there no it
doesn't it's
funny honey holds it together so you so
so if i go downstairs right now and i
take a bunch of peanuts
and i throw it into a jar of honey and i
scoop it out with a spoon and put in my
mouth am i eating a candy bar
so i swear to god it's not in the shape
of a bar if i went downstairs right now
and i took a lot of peanuts and i
took a lot of honey and i molded a log
a peanut log with the honey i guess did
i just make a candy bar
so the argument is not that the argument
is m
m's are candy they're not a candy bar if
you go and get a box
of those valentine's day chocolates it's
chocolate but it's not a candy bar
you're being so literal i'm saying
eminem's are a kin
to a candy bar they're not all the same
things i thought about that that's what
you said
you said that you counted it as a candy
bar the competition eminem peanut
and eminem everywhere competition of
snickers everything is no
so are skittles but it's not a candy bar
everything in that candy aisle is akin
to the next thing
there it's all the same stuff do you
think m ms are only comparable
to skittles and reese's pieces i don't
understand what what you're thinking no
you can compare them you're a direct
competitor they're a direct competitor
with skittles as well though
it's candy what are we arguing i'm
saying to
well obviously
because it reminds him of his
boyfriend's limp chocolate bar
all right that that one wins obviously
what out of the gate
show i'm just saying why are you arguing
with me
with something so silly i don't get why
you're insisting that
we can't go to pimp because he doesn't
have a mic today if i blindly asked
a hundred people give me your top five
candy bars
do
no because you're saying bars i never
would say i'm not
i'm telling you from people's
perceptions if i asked a hundred people
what their top favorite candy bars are i
guarantee you that some people would
list
eminem's in there no they wouldn't can
they are the same
thing no they're not it's like saying
that
oh my god joe it's like so licorice is a
candy bar
so what are your favorite cameras
somebody's gonna say twizzlers are a
sedan and a jeep
both automobiles yes snickers and m
m's are both candy but what is a candy
bar
two chocolate candy items in different
shapes they're still direct competitors
i didn't say they're not competitors but
i'm not arguing with you that
eminence are a bar they're saying
they're consistent they're considered no
they're not considered no they're
that's the most man i ever got you have
to stop saying that no
i refuse now now that's the only way
i'll refer to it as
m m's is one of my favorite candy bars
that does sound weird should we call
here's my question
let's call somebody call somebody cook
dumb chris
call dumb chris and see what
he says let's see what okay yeah i'm
gonna okay
call him okay let me let's see okay let
me okay ready
let me say what i have to say before you
slap your gums okay here hey babe what's
going on
you're on the podcast you are uh you are
you're on currently
the taste buds podcast on the no press
network
oh my god this is amazing this is what
i've been waiting for
by the way didn't know i was calling
answer the phone hey babe
it's authentic folks yeah so chris
chris chris wait no no no no don't don't
speak
let me speak and you better cleanse gwen
stefani
all right all right you better set this
up fairly you you better
choose your words carefully how you ask
him to settle this okay
you because one wrong word and it's
going to lean it's you can't
okay chris today we're debating candy
bars
okay and we got uh uh we got snickers
versus kitkat we started talking about
all the candy bars
and we started to name what we think the
biggest powerhouse candy bars are
i'm saying in that category i probably
put
snickers kitkat twix um
was it was the other one i'm forgetting
no what's the other one i'm forgetting
peanut m ms
motherfu i'm thinking of the other candy
bar first man
oh sorry chris there was what was real
reese's okay
so here's oh oh no it's okay all right
shut up
okay chris i say the top five probably
most popular or biggest selling candy
bars are twix
reese's peanut butter cups um snickers
kitkat and peanut m ms is that five yes
would you agree or disagree with any of
those and if so why
so you're saying reese's kit kats
snickers peanut m
ms and twix are the top five highest
selling candy bars well i think they're
the most popular or even maybe maybe the
most selling but i would put those as
maybe the five biggest powerhouses
you're in the world of canada you're
presenting this in
in the only thing i'll say to you
and and i would say out of all those
five
for me it's kit kit kat at the top of
the list
twix at the bottom but the thing that
you're forgetting and the thing
i think that if i was in there what i
would be pushing hard for
is nobody better lay a finger on my
butterfinger oh curveballs
hold on chris chris
chris sal completely pointed you in the
wrong direction that's not where we were
debating
the argument is this i said sal you're
talking top five candy bars
m m's aren't a candy bar he insisted
over and over that m m's count as a
candy bar i said sal
we looked up the definition of candy bar
it literally said candy
shaped in the form of a bar i go just
because it's candy doesn't mean it's a
candy bar let me speak now
uh fellow kitkat he says i want to hear
what he says
why can't i defend because because you
you i let him defend
i let him respond to what you said first
respond to that chris
um listen if we're talking about this
best
specificity of a candy bar yeah then
yeah i'd have to say that
m m's is a candy shell candy
okay chris my point here is no [ __ ] is
sitting here
arguing the literal shape of the
candidate
my point was the peanut m m's the cups
they are akin
to chocolate candy bars they're in the
same class they are the
direct competitor and when people rank
them they would include those because
they will encapsulate
what a chocolate bar means the top five
candy bars here's the thing
all right i think because i got i got i
gotta run out i gotta run out and do
this thing
um you gotta do it uh podcast from uh
logan paul's
uh guest room
guys all right he's got he listen to me
chris got to go he got a
dixie dimilio's pantry they're shooting
something in the pantry
and guess what it's going to get 90
million views and chris is going to
drive home in a convertible
country right now yeah and and
here's the thing one thing i'll say is
the butterfinger but if we're talking
about candy bars
for me guns in my head any candy bar if
i just save one candy bar
for me to be the hershey's dark
chocolate bar and i don't know
hang up on him hang up on him
[Music]
is that what it's for is that what it's
for you gotta get your
you gotta you gotta get
you gotta get you picked a dark
chocolate hershey's bar
you make me sick dude oh god dude
i hope you go to prison one day
we were talking about you earlier and i
said i was talking to keith robinson and
dante nero on the phone today
and keith your name came up and keith
goes i like chris
but he's dumb
[Laughter]
why are you why would you pick the dark
chocolate candy bar
dude why does er what'd you say wait a
minute here's my point which
let me go back to what sal was saying
he's going he's going dude they're
they're competitors with snickers so m
m's count as a kitty where i go
skittles are competitors with snickers
all candies competes with all candy
it's candy it's like that's my point
there's a candy bar is a thing
pieces get chocolate that doesn't matter
it's like saying
well let's listen to it crazy pebbles
are different than cocoa pebbles
because they're chocolate or whatever
when i chris when i said to you these
are the top five bars
you didn't go whoa whoa sal peanut m ms
is not it's not a bar
because you accepted the fact that
they'd be in the same category
pip i want you to pimp i want you to
type in you want to bust
our eminem's a candy bar oh and the
trailer
gotcha guess what else chris guess what
else behind the scenes for backyard bar
wars
m m's m m's had to come out with a candy
bar and specifically say
look now we have a candy bar and this
in puerto rican wrapped up in an italian
is is saying that it's not true
[Laughter]
that would be my ingredients if it was a
candy bar
it's a chunky italian outside with a
creamy puerto rican center
but here's the thing for me i guess i
guess being from new york if it's
you know right by the register in a
bodega then anything that's there is a
candy bar yes
oh yes yes that was my exact argument
thank you it's candy it's not a candy
bar
oh joe your world is crumbling down
around you
looks like a fly girl from a living
color
i want you to go go do your
please go do your you look like santa
claus on break
yeah i know go do your uh go do your tv
show where you build out houses in
somebody's yard
now do we know when it's going to be on
yet let's plug it
in backyard bar wars uh hosted by
chrissy d mid july and true tv i
promise you it won't ever see the light
of day
he's going to do something and it's
going to get tabled he's
something
i know the show's going to come out
they're just going to just you know
[ __ ] cue is going to be the house
oh this is a this will let you i don't
want to keep you if you're
like you have to go really really have
to go i i got to go now but i just want
to say
pam's getting out to l.a on monday dude
how about this pimp and my mother are
coming to los angeles on the same flight
oh my god that's hysterical
oh let's this is a good time to announce
the saratoga peanut butter
no press pack is out right now
peanut butter right now i got i got to
go out right now all right later okay
baby
saratoga peanut butter thank you very
much big shout out
to saratoga peanut butter they made
three flavors of
two flavors this is a no brush pack
right now you gotta taste buds
right if you want to throw it up you
guys okay it was a taste buds and then
uh i got to see what you said
it's a hay babe flavor it's called the
no press pack
um now it's finally out we were working
with saratoga peanut butter company
to get our own flavors little backstory
real quick
saratoga found them at like a christmas
fair
years ago love them i've been giving
them as gifts send them to friends
people are addicted they found out that
we liked it turns out it's a
female-owned business
and she's a former staten islander we
hit it off and she agreed to make us
flavors with our
faces and names on the label and it goes
to chap big portion goes to charity
for abused children and uh it's the nova
so on
what's the website yo peanut.com
yeah the hate babe flavor is uh
chocolate with almond butter and
blueberries
and the taste buds flavor is
butterscotch peanut butter flavor
uh they are delicious it's my favorite
peanut butter and
uh support uh oh do we
remember her name off hand well support
saratoga and this lovely woman who i'm
sorry
a great brand that means it's healthy
four grams of sugar
seven grams of protein so it's charity
yeah it all goes to charity so
so that's achievement unlocked this is a
big thing in my life
i know i love it and the names of the
podcasts yeah and
you know no pressure and it's a no
pressure pack which is nice i love
the network actually getting a little
love too yeah yeah so thank you so much
for taking this on with us
thank you so much for giving a portion
of the proceeds to charity
and for putting our faces on your
product that's crazy all right this has
been the craziest episode
ever 90 something else and 10
debate about snickers kitkat but that's
what you're gonna get from us sometimes
sometimes it's fly by the seat of our
pants
and you give what you get and i will say
this this was the most comprehensive
episode we've ever done
we have we covered candy today yes we
covered candy
for on all fronts all candy bars i love
it uh
let's see who the winner is peanut
butter cups all the kids oh no we do the
we did the comments first sorry um
you want to read them your glasses oh
yeah please listen uh kit-kats are
almost as bad as real cats
all right mark it that might be the
winner that might be the winner
that's actually really funny that's
great wow wait hold on a second though
great joke but there's not one person
that's going to tell me a kit kat is not
good
well she thinks he gets so bad no one
will agree with her
find me the human walking this earth
that says kit-kats are not good
uh it's it's a gut that was a gut punch
tweet uh snickers are the divorced
parents of candy
and you only want one if you need
chocolate and it's your only option
that's funny i'm sorry but i'm always in
the mood for a far too
i'm sorry but i'm not always in the mood
for a far too chewy candy bar that hurts
my throat
i can't not complaining about that well
which one's he talking about
it is too chewy what do you mean you
think a kitkat is chewy i talked all
about snap
i think that i think the kitkat has
better chance of hurting your throat
nah nah nah nah that well that wafer
immediately breaks down with a little
bit of saliva i've had a chewy kitkat
before i have
you get out of town you eat the snickers
and the snickers by the way
god god forbid you got a filling or
something like that in your tooth
that thing is gonna cement the between
the nougat and the caramel
your teeth are getting jacked up do you
think that dusty chocolate on the
kitkat's going to do
same thing no it's not going to bond to
your to your
it's not going to bond to your uh root
canal and rip it apart
no stickers is dangerous chris only
agreed with you because you guys have a
podcast together at the end there's not
true i don't
buy that you have a podcast network with
him listen to me all right can i just
say something about the peanut too
speaking of saratoga i love the peanut
in the form of a butter
i don't know we're talking about a
peanut on its own peanut is on the low
end
i already said this i said that the
peanut version the snickers bar peanut
is the best way to have a peanut it's
drenched in caramel it's a great way to
have it because stand alone it's not
worth
nothing i agree with you i'm a cashew
you could buy a bucket of like honey
roasted peanuts for like fish
i'm a cashew man and a pistachio man
myself all right let's read two more and
then we got to get to we got to wrap
this thing up
kit kats are delicious plain and simple
joe derosa will obviously pick
snickers because it reminds me oh we
already read that one sorry
if you like that many nuts in your mouth
that's between you and your childhood
you gotta read it you can't laugh
through it they don't see this
if you like that many nuts in your mouth
that's between you and your childhood
trauma
break me off a piece of that kick cat
and last but not least snickers is the
overrated
is overrated the you're not you
when you're hungry is dumb because i
never i'm never full after eating a
snickers i'm just on a sugar high
i got to tell you right now buddy people
are not really being kind to the
snickers
our winner is kitkat is almost as bad as
real cats who said that
uh we're gonna retweet the uh
yeah cool a243 at k-o-o-l-a-243
okay beautiful now let's go to the polls
and
what do you feel like right now do you
feel like you have a shore win i'm
surprised at the amount of kitkat love
in the comments
um and i think i think people are more
endeared to a kit kat
i told you you gotta it resonates with
fun and and childhood
i think you have a really good thing
this is like an adult bar on the run
i think you have a real snickers might
be the boomer we got
candy bar oh my god so this time we put
it out since the episode was so long we
got more votes but then i
quote tweeted it instead of replying and
whereas sometimes we have seven
fifteen twenty thousand votes we have
forty nine thousand votes right now
all right forty nine thousand votes on
this in the figure
oh my god
oh oh my god i don't even wanna record
anymore today
i just wanna float around on my cloud
that's what i want to do i want to you
know i want to go for a walk right now
and enjoy nature
because i'm on cloud nine because i not
only did i win
that is a decisive 30 percent win
this is this blows me away that's enough
49 000 votes for get got to win
61.9 to 38.1
i am blown away i can't believe i wasn't
even arguing with that much uh
confidence because i didn't think i
didn't i didn't think i did
we peg snickers as the pinnacle
the one and who's going to beat snickers
well it looks like
who's going to be cat no it really does
look like that i want to know
who's going to be you know what we
should do we should do a candy bar
bracket
why don't we do that all right because
this is there's just too many let's do a
candy bar bracket you got kitkat
i mean i wouldn't even put those up
together in the first round i would have
seated them differently
i
are you serious i can't believe that
level of up
that's not even like that's four that's
the most votes we've ever had in an hour
49 000 votes well congrats man
i mean i feel very satisfied right now
it's almost like i had a snickers
like that just keep moving in there yeah
yeah you ready for a break
yeah i'll do it i'm gonna keep doing it
because it's stupid
and it's fun you're supposed to say i
still love you i know but i do still
love you
okay but you got to say it though i
still love you no you say to me because
i won
no the winner i still love you remember
when it was your idea to do the comments
so we could end the show with the reveal
and then immediately just go i still
love you and then end it
now you never do it because you never
remember to do it okay
yeah i'm just trying to keep us on the
track of your idea that you okay
so before we before we cut out a couple
of little things
we're working on it right now i believe
i believe if not just me and you will be
there
we might also might be do we plug this
now no we'll wait
oh can we plug it in i don't know it's
not a done deal yet
let's put it this way there's a comedy
festival coming up
and it looks like we will probably
be doing a live taste buds at it more
details to come
there yeah that's how you do it and i
got toy dates coming up
real soon and they'll all be on
savilecanoncomedy.com
and uh the guys and i are going on tour
uh if it's not on sale yet it will be it
kicks off in october at the td bank
arena in boston
and then goes through the next year and
if those aren't on sale yet they will be
but we're gonna we'll i'm getting back
out there i'm getting back on the horse
baby good
have some fun out there be safe with the
boys
uh go see the shows obviously they're
they're you know obviously
but um check out my other podcast
we'll see you in hell pat walsh and i
review genre films
uh episodes wherever you get your
podcasts new episodes exclusively on
patreon patreon.com
wsyihpodcast i still love you
still love you boys see ya bye taste
buds
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to the mic i'm talking taste buds